My name is Alexa and I live with an Alexa.
Sorry, I didn't understand the question I heard.
The first time I realized there was trouble with having a robot...
...share my name in my house...
...was when I realized my parents would talk more to the robot than to me.
Alexa, get me some water.
Amazon's choice for water is Fiji Natural Artesian Water.
Would you like to buy it?
They would ask her for things like the weather or to play a game...
...or to play music, even though I wanted to listen to music...
...and I wanna play games too.
I think I've got it.
You are thinking of Tinkerbell.
Thanks for playing.
A day in the life of having two Alexas in a house is a lot of confusion.
There's a lot of stopping.
"Are you talking to me?"
"Are you talking to the robot?"
You never know.
One time, I was playing with my dogs and my mom's from the kitchen yelling,...
"Alexa, stop!"
And I'm thinking I'm doing something wrong.
Am I hurting the dog?
My worst nightmare.